i
very much enjoyed this i thought it was
quite a wild story
when the opportunity to play one of
these nine perfect strangers came your
way what was it that got you
most interested and excited about it
melissa mccarthy she's the one that
reached out and uh let me know about it
and
she's she's a good friend and she was
looking out for me and she said you know
this could be interesting because we've
never done this before i've never seen
you play this kind of character he's
really interesting
so i read it and uh and i read the book
and and i thought um
i just thought it was a good exploration
of trauma and
the different ways that people try to
work through that
and grief and uh and i thought hey in
particular the character was interesting
because he was
like a dichotomy you know he was a guy
who volunteered to be there but then
spent all of his time really
doing everything he he could to get out
of there
and i thought that was a real challenge
to figure out how to make that
interesting and
and i thought it was pretty funny too
you know that somebody could be that
in the depths that deep and yet i
thought there could be some comedic
gold to mine there is there ever a worry
when a friend like that sends you a
project that like what
what do you do if you don't like it are
you someone who is pretty honest like
would you say you know i just i don't
think this works for me
yeah i mean you have to be honest and i
have been in situations like that where
i've had friends um luckily i haven't
had any friendships break up over my
not wanting to do it but um you do have
to be honest you know it's a long time
to spend with
with um a project you know like you
would hope that everybody that's
involved is there because they want to
be there and they believe in it so i
it'd be a tough thing for me to uh
to fake my way through whose decision
was the beard did you comp
you know contemplate whether to have a
beard or not to have a beard or were you
always going to have a beard for him
no that was me that was my i wanted to
grow the beard i wanted to wear that hat
nobody wanted me to wear that hat that
hat was a big fight but i just thought
i just thought he was a guy who really
didn't want to you know really didn't
want to be recognized
it has probably happened to him before
he does get recognized it happens in the
script and i just thought
what would this guy try to do to really
really be unrecognizable and so i
i thought well he'd he's addicted to
painkillers so he definitely would gain
weight so i did that and then um
and then yeah i grew the beard um
yeah really just to lend lend a little
bit more mystery to the guy a little
more
kind of letting himself go you know i
think the guy's at the end of his rope
when we meet him and so
i think he's trying his best to
disappear and uh i wanted him to look
that way it's why i wanted his clothes
to be
20 years old if you're gonna
get screwed around with by anyone it
seems like nicole kidman
is a good choice to have do that to you
what did you most enjoy about exploring
the dynamic with her
character and how is the experience of
having her as a scene partner
in this role yeah well so you know the
character
i like very much how the character
brings an air of mystery
about them um and yet the actor who
plays them has to be filled with
a really deep well of complexity um and
you know nicole's been doing this for a
while she's played a lot of different
roles and i i'm always impressed with
just how
much she takes on you know it's it's
hard to work that much and
not repeat yourself and and she's a
great example of somebody who just
challenges herself so much so
i was excited to get to work with her
because i thought well this is such a
weird character there's just so much
going on here but
you know the writing supports that
history and particularly the way that
that information is parsed out in the
show and how we figure out how we
learn about her experience and her
trauma i thought that the character was
compelling on the page
um and i just knew that she was going to
bring something to it that
would make those scenes charge
particularly those early up those
early scenes with tony when we don't
know enough about we don't know
a lot about either of them but something
happens
in that room i think tony's the kind of
character that like
you you you kind of he's so forceful
that character his nature is so forceful
that it's a good idea to have him in
conflict with her
very early on when you don't know much
about them and
and so it was uh i looked forward to
shooting those scenes and we did shoot
them pretty early when
i didn't really know nicole that much so
there's this sort of sense of trying to
figure each other out in that scene that
was very real
there's also some wild stuff that
happens in the show could you ever
have imagined that you do a project
where you had a scene
in which luke evans was birthing your
baby i mean what was that
like to shoot funny i've
almost forgot about that scene i don't
know how but maybe it's a mental block
oh we laughed so hard we laughed so hard
and then you've got everybody in the
cast
at the foot of the bed yeah you know
loving it
it was so weird it was so weird but you
know
it's a dream sequence so that's what's
fun about a dream sequence you can do
anything i think there's another scene
if it's still in there where i've got
like a long haired wig um
and uh like i'm like a romance novelist
cover boy
um and those are always fun because you
can you can do anything in a dream right
uh and when you when you
when you consider why they're having
those kinds of dreams
it's even more fascinating i think but
that's
like a reveal that comes later in the
show what is your reaction to the ending
of the series and where things are left
for all of these characters but
specifically for your character
well you know i think it's um i like the
ending of it you know
um i think some things are left unsaid
some things are left pretty vague i
think that like the
characters heal in some way or another
they're not completely healed but
they're not completely broken i think at
the beginning of the
of the story they're all pretty close to
completely broken whether they're
whether they're showing it or not but
all of those characters at one point
luke's character says you know she chose
us specifically she curated us and i
think that that's true and i think the
thing they have in common is that they
are
as broken as one can possibly be and so
by the end of that thing
the end of that experience um i think
that they're in a better place certainly
than they were when they got there and i
think
you know if there's any message to be
taken away there might be something to
taking the time for yourself to um shake
it up a bit shake the tree as it were
was there a most challenging part of
this shoot or most challenging scene or
is it all just
fun when you're doing something as kind
of wild and crazy as this gets
you know i think the physical thing was
was the like
the more physical scenes were
challenging um if only because i just i
gained so much weight and i wasn't
really
taking good care of myself and um and so
anytime i had to run i was i was a bit
worried because
i've got bad knees and i wasn't in shape
and
and i had to yet i had to cut and i was
playing this injury you know and
so for me it was more physically
challenging than other roles but
you know a big part of that was just
really having to continually stay in a
place of
physical pain you know that's something
that jonathan levine and i talked a lot
about that this guy doesn't like get up
from a chair without it really
hurting and so sort of living in that
place was
something that i had to stay very
focused on and
and that was that was that was pretty
challenging well i appreciate you
talking to me about it i found all these
characters so
interesting so thank you oh thanks
christina thank you
thanks a lot